se cumplen 10 días desde que entró en
erupción el volcán cumbre vieja y la
lava está a punto de tocar el mar se
calcula que desembocará a 8 km de la
reserva natural de la palma una de las
tres con las que cuenta el archipiélago
canario los oceanógrafos y vulcanólogos
españoles siguen minuto a minuto el
fenómeno continuamos procesando datos
físicos y geológicos a contrarreloj a
bordo del ramón margalef ante la posible
llegada de la colada al mar la comunidad
científica española espera que la
entrada en contacto del magma con el
agua sepultar a muchas formas de vida en
la costa pero que a medio plazo
regenerar a un ecosistema más rico como
sucedió diez años atrás a raíz de una
erupción submarina cerca de la isla del
hierro la erupción del volcán desde el
punto de vista científico no se
considera una catástrofe de hecho la
actividad volcánica produce compuestos
como el ácido sulfúrico que enfrían la
atmósfera sin embargo la colada ha
arrasado con cientos de inmuebles y
fincas de cultivos y cerca de seis mil
personas han sido desalojadas por lo que
el gobierno español ha declarado la isla
de la palma zona gravemente afectada por
una emergencia de protección civil para
de un plan especial de asistencia
concretamente estamos hablando de una
concesión de una subvención directa lo
haremos a través de la comunidad
autónoma a través de la comunidad de
canarias será una subvención directa del
estado de 10,5 millones de euros para
atender compra de vivienda para ponerla
en alquiler o también para que pueda ser
adquirida por por las personas que lo
precisen y también adquisición de
enseres de primera necesidad
previsiblemente el choque de la lava con
el mar producirá nubes de gases tóxicos
pero los científicos aseguran que si se
respetan los perímetros de seguridad no
tienen por qué causar daños humanos